Harley Quinn and Batman are teaming up
for an original adventure in the newest
movie from Warner Brothers animation The
Dark Knight and mistress of mischief
have more in common than you might think
and we scheduled a therapy session with
the legendary Bruce Timm to get all the
details Bruce thanks for joining us on
DC all-access absolutely now can you
tell us a little bit about the premise
of Batman and Harley Quinn it's a action
slash comedy probably with a little bit
more of an emphasis on the comedy in
broad strokes it's kind of like 48 hours
of superheroes is that meant having to
team up with Harley Quinn to stop poison
ivy the latest from world-threatening
Rock was this inspired by any Batman of
Harley Quinn story specifically I mean
there was an episode that we did back in
the old days called Harlequin aid which
was had basically the same rough
plotline so it certainly falls into the
template of that episode but it's the
story specifically pretty job well and
since Batman Harley Quinn have to sort
of team up in this movie what is the
relationship like the relationship
between Batman and Harley in this movie
is it's interesting it's kind of like
CERN dad and his really bratty teenage
daughter she you know Batman's like he's
like a controller to control freak you
know and he's constantly trying to get
Harley to do what he wants her to do and
she always manages to find a way to get
her own way throughout the whole movie
where I can help you find him but you're
going to put in a good word for me with
a grown boy know so that's kind of fun
at the same time you know he kind of
needs her and he's not he's not exactly
a people person you know not really so
so yeah so you know he it's you know
he's constantly frustrated throughout
the entire movie because like I said he
tries to get her to go left and she's
going to go right and up and down all
the same time now this movie also has
the first animated appearance of
Veronica man yeah now can you tell me a
little bit about why now why didn't we
need parodic man I'm just moving I kind
of thought it made kind of phobias kind
of sense to kind of see seeing him up
with poison ivy
they're plant-based villains this is no
hoard their relief Evo's what a
harbinger of the new wage they both be
the kind of the horrible thing that that
man against the world against the
warming and pollution so we've seen a
lot of different versions of Harley
Quinn's that she premiered in Batman the
Animated Series but for you what is it
about Harley that makes her Harley
she needs to be unpredictable need to be
funny if she does have you know
different shades or as well who says
that different dimensions actually she
does have an interesting eternal life
those are a really complicated backstory
I think bottom line is despite all the
other things that are interesting about
her I think she needs to be funny
holy quick reporting but you're in shock
good helpless the world premiere of
Batman of Harley Quinn will be at San
Diego comic-con which is right around
the corner and if you can't make it des
deep don't worry
stay tuned the DC all-access because
we're going to have wall-to-wall
coverage of San Diego plus we have a new
DC video every single weekday
see you tomorrow Superfriends